you think we're ready for it
i think we're i think we're beyond ready
for a third party what do you call that
third party independent libertarian or a
new party i could care less it needs a
whole new name
not independent or libertarian a whole
new name libertarians have been trying
at it for how long
well they have boring candidates thank
you gosh they have boring
and i had to text somebody a few days
ago and say who's this person i mean we
talked about in the podcast that's a
police stop with these videos there's
just
nice person she seems sweet but come on
you need a
person that's going to get out there and
be a little bit bolder so bold
yeah so is it more individual or is it
more party
because there's got to be somebody you
get behind you need
someone to be the voice you do you need
somebody
and a bunch of people behind them also
running for a bunch of important
senate and house seats at the same time
you're looking at a you know you're not
looking at an eight-year-run though
you're not making changes in eight years
though
i'm not dead yet no i know that but what
i'm saying and they say that this
generation z is on fire
yeah they say gen z is ready to rock and
roll
ready to work hard if we i mean if we
need a change agent apparently we've got
them
have you ever talked to trump's camp or
no yeah
you ever spoke in a pence camp no never
have
i speak with a secret service
contingency when i'm driving around
culver when he's got his family reunion
there but that's the closest
as i've come what are your aspirations
with politics you sound like you're
you know you could you could inspire
some people i am happy to back any
movement that's rational
i really am i have a voice i'm i clearly
i'm not quiet
i'm ready to use my voice to bring about
change in this country because i love my
children and i want their future to be
different
do you have plans of running no at all
why not
it could be past my time
i think we need somebody young we need
it we need to you know
what do you tell me it's past your time
we need a kennedy but not his politics
but we need somebody who is young and
charismatic
and can pull the whole country together
yeah but you're you're not you're you're
saying it's not just presidency you're
saying
other positions other positions so but
here's a problem you ready
um people who are smart like you
who have great lives don't want to run
don't want to run
i mean you you want to fix it but you
don't want to run maybe i'd be
maybe i'd be like the person who finds
people no
you're being over there you'll be like
the regular i'll go recruit people i
will
[Music]